Android Wear uses voice throughout the
platform, and one of the best places to
see it in action is doing
replies to notifications.
Normally when you touch
the reply action on a phone,
it'll take you to an activity
to enter the text.
On Android Wear, the user can touch this
reply button and then speak a reply and
it is then converted into a string and
delivered to your app.
Best of all, you can use this feature
with just a few lines of code,
added to your existing
notifications on the phone.
We use a class called
RemoteInput to implement this.
We declare a string extra_voice_reply
that specifies the key
that will be delivered
to the intent later on.
We also declare a label to
put on the text reply screen
telling the user what we
want them to speak to us.
You then call build to get
the remote input object.
Now we need to add the remote
input to our notification.
You can see here we declare a pending
intent to receive the reply.
We then create an action and
then we use addRemoteInput to use the
remote input object we created earlier.
Then we use extend on the notification
to add a wearable extender, add action,
and the action we just created.
Everything is now linked together,
and we can issue the notification.
This code will continue
to work on a phone, but
now we can have a reply action that
asks the user to speak a reply.
So how do we get the reply string back?
The previous code is written to use
an activity called reply activity.
Inside there, you can call get intent
to find details about the intent that
started the activity.
Once you have the intent,
you can pass it to the getMessageText
method shown here.
We can then extract out the voice
reply using the key EXTRA_VOICE_REPLY,
which returns a CharSequence
that was spoken by the user.
And that's it.
It's that easy.
Speech recognition has traditionally
been very hard to do by yourself, and
Android Wear takes care of all of it for
you.
There is also support for
emoji entry in Android Wear, and
these are automatically
handled on the wearable, and
sent to your app as standard
emoji unicode characters.
You don't always have
to use voice replies.
Sometimes your user will be
unable to speak to the watch and
they might want to reply with
a set of pre canned replies.
You can use the set choices method
to specify an array of options that
the user can select from to be
used along with a voice reply.
And here's how you define
the array in the strings.xml file.
It contains a set a strings that will
be given to the extra voice replied to
find earlier.
One more thing to note here,
if your using the Android wear emulator,
you'll have to type your
voice replies on a keyboard,
since the emulator does not
support speech recognition.